hello again the top stories on sky world
news turkey says it will increase its
security along its border with Syria
following a suspected Islamic state
attack which killed at least 31 people
the Cuban flag has been raised over the
country's newly reopened embassy in
Washington after the u.s. and Cuba
formally restored diplomatic relations
and outgoing FIFA president Sepp Blatter
has been showered with fake money at a
news conference as he announced reforms
to football's world governing body now
turkey says it will increase security
along its border with Syria following a
suspected is suicide blast which killed
at least 31 people the attack in the
border town of Surak is the worst at
terror attack carried out on Turkish
soil for many many years earlier on we
spoke to the journalist Orion Jones
who's in Istanbul exactly devastating
attack on Turkey I mean this is by one
of the worst suicide bombings the
country has experienced in many many
years the fact that we're talking about
the most of the dozens of people killed
and scores more injured or away young
teenagers in the early 20s university
students who were going to a summer camp
which aimed to rebuild a library in the
nearby Syrian Kurdish town of kobani
which was just across the border but has
only added to the shock and anger in the
country and again it is raised the whole
question about how secure are turkeys
borders with Syria the whole of the
Syrian border has been controlled by
Islamic state for a long period of time
and there's been a great deal of concern
of a fact that people have been going
backwards and forwards across the border
with near impunity according to critics
of turkey Turkey has a reputation of
being known as the super super highway
for jihadists into Syria and Iraq now
the Turkish authorities have always said
this is a difficult border we're talking
about 900 kilometers to monitor but they
have seen appear to a stepped up their
efforts in the last few weeks we're
talking about several hundred people
have been to tame many of them believe
the beach would be jihad is seeking to
enter Syria so turkey has does appear to
be heeding pressure
from its Western Allies in particular
from the UK and the US and are taking
steps but having said that in spite of
those measures this suicide bomber
managed to get across and carry out this
absolutely deadly attack and leading
members of turkeys main pro-kurdish
party having been slow coming forward
they say that much of the blame lines
lines at the doorstep of the government
they say that they still haven't failed
they still failed to secure turkey
borders against such attacks and the
warning from even while the members of
turkeys ruling party is if it is Islamic
state he won't this will not be the last
at turkey will face and that is a big
fear particularly is turkey had very
large tourism you're talking about the
Mediterranean and the AG and some of the
biggest tourist resorts in Europe